[Musique]
c'est un débat qui revient désormais
chaque année à chaque élection de miss
france faut-il ouvrir le concours aux
candidats transgenres et pourquoi vous
n'ouvrez pas ce goncourt aux transgenres
nous sommes en cours de réflexion sur ce
sujet sur cette question-là président de
la société miss france alexia
laroche-joubert semble avoir tranché les
miss transgenres pourront bien
participer au prochain concours on
demande à ce que l'identité civile soit
féminin mais donc ya pas de problème
s'il ya des des transsexuels pourtant il
ya un jour plus tôt sylvie tellier avait
plus ou moins botté en touche lorsque la
question lui avait été posée au micro
d'eurosport il faut rappeler que sont
les français qui élisent les candidates
régionales c'est pas sylvie tellier
s'est pas alexia laroche joubert c'est
pas le producteur de l'émission qu'il en
soit cette décision risque de faire
grand débat alors miss france etes-vous
pour ou contre la participation de
candidats transgenres alizée shane
candidats demi stranger est avec nous ce
soir pour nous faire part de son avis
merci d'être avec nous à lise et merci
d'être là ansa bonsoir transition
terminée depuis quatre ans vous êtes
artiste pour les téléspectateurs qui ne
vous connaissent pas vous avez décidé
voilà de changer de vie pour fait on va
dire d'identité exactement de vie des
identités ya quatre ans il ya quatre ans
j'ai terminé oui j'ai ce qui s'est passé
ma mère avait refait sa vie avec un
compagnon et elle l'a retrouvé mort dans
la douche voilà et ça a été le déclic je
me suis dit la vie est trop courte c'est
ça il faut que je la fasse comme j'ai
envie de faire ouais sinon je me tire
une m'a dit voilà moi je me suis pas
bien sûr m'a sauvé line ou sentait pas
bien comme vous étiez oui voilà le
concept dit ça y est maintenant je veux
avec à quel âge
devient-on donc là je peux vous demander
votre âge encore vous avez 25 ans
aujourd'hui vous en avez quoi 29-32
adacore 32 commentons ça vous a pris
c'est un prix trois ans et deux mois
entre le premier rendez vous avec le psy
jusqu'à la résine plastique d'accord
vous c'est quoi comme le métier moi je
travaillais dans un fast-food d'accord
suite en sortant du lycée après je suis
parti dans le spectacle parce que pour
moi c'était la seule manière de gagner
ma vie en étant enfin c'est ça alors
avons vous étiez que vous appeliez
comment vous étiez à bassa je répondrai
pas gérer c'est la question qui se pose
pas elle n'est pas d'accord c'est ce
même mois il n'y a pas d'avis
je pose des questions comme ça
pas censé savoir vraiment nouvelle vie à
ces nouvelles vies c'est une renaissance
comme on dit je repars à zéro le livret
de famille a été changée mais bah ouais
aussi ça a pris six mois les papiers
personnellement est ce que vous êtes
heureuse mais complètement là ça y est
je serai pas là pour en parler avec vous
sentez bien ouais et votre entourage
comme il l'a pris à mon père l'a très
mal pris ma soeur ça a été un peu
difficile aussi maintenant ça se passe
super bien ma mère par contre ma
compagne et du premier rendez vous je
sais au dernier c'est votre mère qui le
déclic ouais j'ai été agressée t'es
vachement plus proche de ma mère que de
mon père donc elle m'a accompagné à tous
mes rendez-vous à elle a été là et
maintenant en plus je fais un bisou à
les malades donc maintenant c'est moi
qui la soutient alors maintenant on a
donc la prochaine étape si vous vous
présentiez au concours miss france je ne
peux pas alors sur le peut pas parce que
je n'ai plus l'âge n'est pas le style
mais je me suis inscrite à notre
concours à nice esthétique france
d'accord parce que alexia
laroche-joubert la présidente de la
société miss france a fait une annonce
ce matin en donnant l'impression que ça
a toujours été le cas il dit que voilà l
on va le sera avec nous après un
d'ailleurs elle est pour voilà ce
concours concours évolué regarde
toujours dit mais ça si vous lisez bien
règlement on demande à ce que l'identité
civile soit féminin mais donc ya pas de
problème s'il ya des des transsexuels et
des transsexuels kong hong kong cheminer
vers l'identité une carte des densités
ces lignes il ya aucun problème mais
vous allez je vais demander à mes hockey
ici
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais reste pauvre moi
je suis pour complètement mais ce qui
serait bien aussi c'est d'enlever le mot
transsexuels en permanence d'accord je
veux dire j'ai fini mon parcours je suis
une femme donc point voilà donc ça voilà
voilà alors qu'est pour qui est contre
ici à la cabane à jour aujourd'hui
influenceurs vous cette prise de
position il vous plait pas des plus
grands noms elle me plaît pas parce que
j'ai l'impression que c'est une énième
pénétration de la web culture
dans des
dans la culture française et en plus là
alexia laroche joubert quand elle dit
que la femme enfin que la personne fait
sa transition pour devenir une femme
elle fait appel à la chirurgie
esthétique
non
si on enlève des testostérones pour
avoir des dérapages il ya pas de
chirurgie esthétique réparatrice
intentions mais pas esthétique est donc
d'accord mais tu est il que moi je
trouve que le corps de la femme de l'eau
corps de la personne est modifié et est
par conséquent elle ne peut pas
concourir à miss france et puis je pense
que miss france pour beaucoup de gens
pour beaucoup de français eh ben c'est
décès des femmes et excusez moi et pour
moi beaucoup de physique sexuelle pour
beaucoup de français avait une compagne
mais si tout de suite je me mets tout nu
à côté d'elle les choses seront à la
même place nettement pareil mais moi
aussi d'ailleurs
mais c'est à dire que si même entêtement
à jamais une
je vais être un peu caricatural mais si
moi demain je mets une perruque je peut
concourir à miss france
alors c'est ça le problème c'est que les
gens ils font l'amalgamé entre le
travesti la transe des rallyes c'est
comme une femme
oui
j'ai quoi devant vous j'ai un nom je
suis pas content à gilles et non mais
c'est pas la question et trams ans
j'aimais pas de jugement j'essaie
d'avoir une lecture globale j'ai
l'impression que pour beaucoup de gens
est bon pour moi y compris les femmes
trans excusez moi c'est peut-être mon
ressenti mais pour moi les femmes trans
ne sont pas tout à fait des femmes donc
on vous dit que vous ne fréquentez pas
un savoir
peut-être oui peut-être et peut-être que
je me suis fait du rappel toi de ta
dernière soirée
[Rires]
c'est un peu con et j'ai l'impression de
que c'est du bon sens mais bien pour
beaucoup de gens le lait les femmes ou
les hommes trans ne sont pas tout à fait
des femmes alors oui je comprends que
pour beaucoup de gens ça choque d'accord
avec vous là en tout cas c'est guillaume
genton qui est contre et je suis content
moi parce que déjà par définition le
concours miss france il exclut déjà
énormément de femmes les femmes de plus
de 25 ans les femmes qui font moins d'un
mètre soixante dix les femmes mariées
dont on sait qu'il n'est pas
représentatif et puis en plus comme les
dix villes comme la direction lors
joubert les personnes transgenres
peuvent déjà participé sur le papier
effectivement il faut être inscrits à
l'état civil comme étant de sexe féminin
n'est pas né de sexe féminin on voit
bien quelle hypocrisie là dedans on n'a
jamais vu de candidates transgenres
alors vous avez vous allez me dire on
nous l'a peut-être pas dit mais
évidemment qu'ils auraient communiqué
là-dessus je trouve qu'il ya de
l'hypocrisie là dedans et de toute façon
miss france n'est pas représentatif de
toutes les femmes voilà vous êtes contre
moi pour moi vous ne devriez pas avoir
envie de participer à ce concours dans
le sens où les minorités ne sont pas
acceptés allez france bat bien sûr à des
formes bien situation j'ai lu pas mal
oui mais la différence d'aider des
femmes chez miss france ça ne marche pas
il faut des femmes dans des cases il
faut des femmes de tous types de
personnes avec un physique et c'est donc
moi je pense que vous devrez pas avoir
envie d'aller à miss france et la caisse
ne se pose même pas mais de toute façon
je pense que avant que ça arrive il va
se passer énormément de temps parce que
pour moi c'est que des mots pour
l'instant même si c'est très bien en
sortir ça peut aller vite en mai je
pense que ce sera en mai prochain jésus
qui produit en septembre
ce que sylvie tellier avait dit une fois
le parcours est tellement long alors
voilà enfin du raku on appuie là j'ai
pas testé dans les instances régionales
il ya une jeune femme qui nous regarde
là qui a subi toutes ces transformations
qui nous regarde là qui se dit eh bah
tiens moi maintenant j'ai envie qui fait
partie de de la case dans laquelle on
peut être concourir pour me laisser je
serai bien présent mais parce que c'est
en toile si vos papiers fraser on pourra
ensuite arriver je trouve que c'est
injuste pour toutes les autres femmes en
fête qui voudraient participer au
congrès pour coiffer non pas les exclut
pas non basset additionne monde comme
parce que elle elle va bien elle va dire
pourquoi il faut faire plus d'un mètre
72 ouais ouais bah voilà mais c'est moi
ne faut pas
non mais c'est ça il ya des quelques
valeurs dans un concours voile alors
après moi que de lancer plein ici on
s'est plaint ici que ce concours
n'évoluez pas ils évoqueront des mandats
il avec sir fait bien bougé et oui il
hilare et koh-lanta kelly y va si on est
si long des quais librairie ml je suis
très déçu de votre position vous ne
modernise enfin c'est la modernité c'est
l'entrée balle là vous êtes rétrograde
la danse
et la modernité qui ont dans le concours
c'est un nouvel élan
enfin les femmes transgenres comme vous
madame vont pouvoir compréhensible
sauf eia georgie george eddy que vous
dites n'importe quoi non non je n'irai
pas jusque là mais ok j'avais jusque là
il ya un nom il ya deux choses que je
voudrais dire la première c'est que
pourquoi vous ne vous focalisez pas sur
un concours trans où il y aurait quelque
chose que je veux dire
c'est bien mais ensuite et deuxième
chose que surtout pour gilles verdez il
ne faut pas dire faut l'accepter parce
que c'est la modernité la modernité ça
s'interroge pourquoi on fait comme ça et
comme dans tout concours je dire les
concours pour les grandes écoles c'est
pareil les concours pour polytechnique
c'est pareil à dîner dans un restaurant
mais remède pour 30 non mais c est vite
east c'est malheureux mais les élites et
les meilleurs que
moi d'abord votre parcours je trouve
formidable et j'espère que vos fans vous
avez l'air très heureuse et c'est ça qui
compte en revanche pour miss france moi
je suis pas d'accord parce qu'en fait je
trouve qu'on est aveuglé par un lanceur
de progressisme un peu à la mode web que
vous avez raison c'est à dire qu'il ya
des critères et à partir du moment où il
ya des critères mais en fait vous vous
n'êtes pas dans les critères même si on
veut vous mettre dans les critères si
elle remplace qualité non non elle
rentre pas dans les noms elle rend pas
de rien parce que vous parlez de nommer
vire jouer sur les ongles dans les clans
elle nous jouer sur les mots parce qu'il
ya quand même une chirurgie réparatrice
family chirurgie réparatrice on sait pas
alors ça va être quoi les critères bon
quand même on a fait quand même là
on avait c'est un petit peu la bosse on
a fait une petite fille est donc une fin
pour une imbécile une femme qui aurait
eu un accident de voiture qui était le
papa si elle pourrait pas le faire
chaque
fois qu'ils m'envoient on dit plus
tranchant on dit transgenre et non plus
deux transsexuels vous dites est ce que
ça me saoule ce genre de truc qu'on veut
on prend comme ça ou est ce que vous
dites voilà parce que c'est pas c est ce
que ça aussi moi personnellement
ça m'insupporte quand des individualités
parce que je rappelle mais je respecte
tout à fait votre votre pensée mais je
rappelle que les femmes les trans ne
représentent que 0,1 pour cent de la
population française ces quinze mille
personnes selon des estimations et moi
ça m'énerve qu'on me dise à moi et aux
français ah bah maintenant tu dois
parler autrement je veux dire on a tous
à peu près d'être éduqué non non ça
s'appelle pas être éduqué chez désolé
je sais pas mais c'est ce que je disais
non mais ses lacets mine de rien c'est
c1 c'est juste voilà c'est la modernité
aussi
des nouveaux mots qu'il arrive dans le
désert c'est vrai quoi si ce n'est pas
méchant ce que j'ai juste que ce jeune
homme ne s'est pas du tout méchant
collier pardon monsieur mal pris mais
effectivement il faut apprendre aux gens
parce que j'avoue que c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui on entend tranche jean
transsexuels non genre et bisexuels navy
n'est pas compliqué donc il faut que
tout ça et il faut expliquer aux gens
ayant expliqué j'entends même il ya un
sous jacent dans chaque terme c'est que
les terres ne sont pas neutres donc on
va quand on va dire à quelqu'un non non
ne me mets genre pas dix mois appelez
moi pour mon vrai prônons le neuneu fin
on est ou ccc de fascisme des mots qua
non mais je serais désolé je les en
votre question je ne participe pas à
miss france ou miss tran stars
internationales où tous les concours qui
existe tout simplement parce que je me
considère pas comme une transe d'accord
moi je suis une femme c'est comme si je
vous parle de transfert de transport de
transfusion s'est passé d'un point a à
un point b you my hand et se termine je
suis arrivé au point b donc ça ne me
concerne plus que aujourd'hui il existe
un concours que vous avez excusez moi
c'est ça mais aucun sur miss esthétique
où ça regroupe justement tout ce que
vous demandez les femmes rondes l'émail
est ce que vous avez
c'est est-ce que vous avez imposées aux
gens de vous reconnaître comme femme bah
oui là c'est là où
bon jour mais
j'aimerais qu'on a j'aimerais qu'on ait
la vie qui est également âgé une
personne animalière une chauve souris
guillaume jamais il faut dire la vérité
c'est triste aujourd'hui un vrai malaise
autour des personnes transgenres et je
pense que il ya certaines chaînes qu'ils
voient la miss france c'est une émission
en prime qui regardaient pas 80
personnes ya des enfants qui regardent
il ya plein de gens c'est pas mon
opinion mais qu'ils voient je ne veux
pas que mes enfants voient ça c'est pas
des biens il ya eu un feeling récemment
s'est passé sur terre et
un téléfilm ya pas longtemps sur ce
sujet sur tf1 et qui a fait l'objet
d'énormément de critiques c'est une
réalité de dire qu'il ya énormément de
gens qui sont mal à l'aise avec sa voix
requis une cérémonie en prime time grand
public et diffusé avec deux enfants qui
regardent dans laquelle on montre des
personnes transgenres c'est une réalité
mathieu que tu l'axé si vous avez l'air
d'accord est un marché entièrement
d'accord je tout ne va pas de soi c'est
compliqué à gérer il faut éduquer les
gens les enfants et pas que et c'est
pour ça que je redis que miss france
évolue c'est très bien parce que c'est
une émission que 10 millions de
personnes ont un peu moins regarde et ça
va faire évoluer les mentalités c'est
pour ça que trouve ça formidable que je
vaux et après
après dans un instant réveillera bernard
montiel
du moment à partir du moment où
effectivement cette femme maintenant et
femmes et donc si c'est pas dit que
c'est précisé personne n'est évidemment
que ça va être un mathieu et dont
l'argent les enfants vont se dire car
si géraldine elle rentre dans les
critères des miss france effectivement
baisser la barre tatoué chirurgie
esthétique
de chirurgie dans le monde n'en sort que
si je vais sur les vrais la cia qui ont
même déjeuné en compagnie non mais c'est
bon je vois que tu possèdes
mais le règlement de miss france doit
changer alors les défis qui alors moi je
suis d'accords salariaux et la mystique
il faut faire gruissan manama la raison
j'en ai presque là la boule jouée sur
les jeunes filles qui s'est fait refaire
le nez elle va dire pourquoi pas moi la
raison
je viens de te prendre un truc l'edl a
les bleus
tu nous fais chier isabelle mais moi
j'ai des poulets bien s'informer mais
attention cette lettre comme isabelle
eva joly compromet pas les qu'elle
comprend pas en dépit des cours de mer
de 6 mois bravo tu es fou c'est le jeu
parce que dans un de ces bêtes on paraît
parfaitement de raison de vous et c'est
un miss esthétique voilà pour effectuer
les lapins des mentalités de masse car
il y aurait forcément des fuites
chicanier cela serait même miss france
avec vous gagnez les gens diront ah oui
ils l'ont fait gagner parce qu'ils ont
peur d'être accusée de d'être réac et
tout et si vous perdez on dira oui de
long ses pertes parce que ils ont appris
et donc du coup ils sont dit que voilà
c'était
paraît très bonne gestion de mon ami
jérôme rodriguez qui m'envoie à bien
salut mon chéri juste une question très
importante les opérations chirurgicales
sont strictement interdites pour le
concours miss notamment ils pourront
prendre des transgenres puisque
forcément elles seront passer sur le
billard c'est cyril aussi un pote qui
même on voit ça ils m'envoient la même
question donc c'est la question que pose
la main sur
yoplait pas gâcher votre jour gagne
roland-garros
tous deux ont fait ça juste parce qu une
transgenre gagne roland garros laquelle
rapport une femme qui sait ce qui était
un homme qui s'est fait opérer qui est
venu nous la mégane roland garros juste
ou pas je n'en sais pas plus
ce débat sur fait toutes les agressions
sont possibles moi je pense je considère
qu'un homme et une femme c'est pas
pareil c'est pas facho de penser sa part
dont le logis la biologie et mathieu tu
crois vraiment que si demain il ya une
candidate transgenres une femme qui
participe à nice france personne ne le
saura évidemment qu'ils vont communiquer
dessus ça va faire jouer la carte de la
diversité soit ça sortira l'on n'a pas
bien sûr parce que évidemment ça
s'enrichir et dans la prédation moi dans
la vie de tous les jours je n'ai aucun
souci on ne montre pas et comment ils
savent alors que les rafales a refait
son nez ou pas ces sujets à débat
évidemment parce que ça a choqué
certaines personnes tu crois vraiment
qu'il mais qu'il ne qui n'en parlerai
pas ça oui si flagrant dans tous les cas
quand on fait une chirurgie quand on est
transgenre il ya une féminisation du
corps quand même donc c'est à dire que
vous modifiez le visage vont modifier le
corps vous munitions certains les heures
noires les au revoir parce qu'on veut
swing ce que vous voulez moi j'ai fait
le choix d'avoir la blessure je vais
choisir vous manque de votre nez vous
pouvez choisir la forme de la mâchoire
voilà oui autre chose donc si le
concours accepte les transgenres à ce
moment là il faut changer toutes les
règles j'ai
trouvé ça bien raison qu'ils soient là
et esthétique c'est pas exact il faut
accepter des gens qui ont fait de la
chirurgie esthétique comme de légende
demande ne pensait pas pardon déclenché
à un tel enjeu sais pas si un a coûté
scandale adhésion alors j'ai eu un
mélange de plein de choses là j'ai
répondu à une question simple d'un
journaliste sur futura yo te sens pas
dire voilà retrait sa part gilles qui me
demande est ce que si un homme qui est
devenue une femme qui a un état civil
féminin peut participer au concours miss
france j'ai répondu en tout cas il peut
parfaitement s'inscrire dans la mesure
où c'est une femme alors évidemment il
ya d'autres critères servette soixante
dix ans frère de survie quand on en a
suffisamment débattu tous ensemble voilà
et je ne crois pas que ça se soit déjà
présenté d'accord donc voilà non pas un
appel à candidatures j'avais déjà dire
ça quand même chirurgie c'est quand même
c'est quand même relativement est la
question qu il est question de la
chirurgie voilà les questions non mais
c'est vrai c'est une vraie question
alors il ya une dans le règlement du jeu
il ya une différence entre la chirurgie
esthétique et la chirurgie réparer nos
jours si bien et et voilà alors je pense
que c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
demandez vous comment vous considérez
entre les secours ont attendu que
j'avais vraiment que veut dire que vous
avez eu raison bah oui m'est avis basé
comme il ya une nuance entre réparatrice
mais qui affine le visage et on peut
décider du nom oui c'est ça met des
coups
excuse-moi alexia je t'aime beaucoup
mais ça ça on joue soirée des tâches les
attendent et vous allez voir bon elle
est d'accord avec nous avec
alexia a dit dorothée pas d'accord avec
le diable donc donc ça c'est un vrai
poids donc là divers on sait qu'à
réparatrice moi je pense que
psychologiquement on sait que ça
s'appelle une chirurgie réparatrice
c'est à dire que le fait que vous
décidiez de changer de sexe on sait que
c'est extrêmement tiré par action oui
voilà ça a un parcours long et dense est
vrai que compte sa rétabli ce que vous
vous êtes profondément en façade accords
sont qu'après il ya la chirurgie
esthétique mais c'est vrai que là il
peut y avoir des mains à dire qu'une
fois voilà une femme une fois que vous
êtes une femme alors il ya tout un
aspect hormonal etc il faudra voir ça
c'est arrivé je vous cache pas que j'ai
pas la reine c'est ça non mais c'est pas
évident à la raison c'est pas étonnant
alors qu'at t a dit on sait pas si on
peut prendre ou pas avec sa nouvelle
poitrine mais aussi à une miss france
par exemple femme qui n'est femmes et
qui n'est très complexée pascal apparent
de poitrine et décide de se refaire une
petite poitrine plus mal mais pas la
plus ronde à ce moment là c'est une
réparation pour lé espèce qu'elle aura
le droit à ce moment-là no et moi j'ai
toujours des rased
les mâles dont la peine ou à l'école un
cas d'école ce soit vrai que non mais ça
pourrait être des belles cas d'école je
suis d'accord que c'est pas simple parce
que réparatrice à leur réparatrice on
sait aussi que c'est de la chirurgie en
cas d'accident de choses comme ça c'est
passé par là c'est grave extrêmement
jalouse après sincèrement j'espère que
je ne souhaite pas de devoir étudier des
dossiers pour savoir si c'est un rêve
une réparation psychologiques n'auraient
pas si on n'est pas psychologue enseveli
merci mais la réalité c'est que si une
femme se présente au concours miss
france on va pas lui demander sûreté un
homme précédemment ça fait partie de
l'intimité de cette personne et de la
vie privée babouins car savoir-faire
pour ses téléspectateurs voilà qu'est ce
qu'il dit pour à 14 85 points
une fois de plus ben haïm et de l'ormeau
vous avez fait c'est pas mal mais
moi je suis papou embauches au courant
alors je suis convoqué j'aurais aimé
qu'elles fassent miss france parce que
je
regardais la tasse clair tu viendras
même anthony ans rémi gaillard comme ça
on repassera en laissant rigoler